the companies want to contract to supply
security infrastructure and personnel
for the 2012 london olympics and this is
a great example to pick on because
olympics by their nature
they are international kinds of events
right and interesting you get
interesting communications technology
questions when you look at these kinds
of
scenarios okay
each week senior management and all of
these officers in all these major um
capital cities participates in a
teleconference sorry southern capital
you know and actually that neither does
that anyway sorry i'll just keep going
big cities
they have a teleconference okay um it's
over the internet and it includes both
audio and video so that's fine pretty
standard sort of setup yeah
all right compare and contrast the use
of teleconferencing with traditional
telephone and face-to-face communication
in this situation all right now
i always feel
silly doing this um because it seems so
obvious and some of you know it so well
but evidently i need to revisit this
with everyone
what are the keywords
compare and contrast it's right there at
the start right it generally is okay now
contrast that's an easy one contrast
means show me the
differences right okay
but compare
means
the opposite right sort of it means show
me the similarities okay now
everyone's really good i mean it's very
obvious to pick out the differences okay
and most people are quite heavy on that
but there are four marks here i'm
looking for similarities too okay
so let's start to um break it down okay
i've got them i'm sort of grouped under
sort of some topics ideas in my head
okay so the first thing which is a big
similarity between the two
is that both of them whoops let's get a
brush out shall we
both of them if we think about the the
telephones um the traditional telephones
i'm thinking about face-to-face
communication later because they're
quite different telephones and
teleconferencing right the tele in
telephone and teleconferencing right
they're both traditional telephones are
traditional methods still the telly
means that it's it's separate it's a
part right there's remote action
happening okay that's why you know say
things like
telekinesis right kinesis as in like
moving stuff that's moving things from a
distance okay that's all that means
all right now if they're both remote
let's think about some of the
similarities here okay they both allow
groups that are um
physically very very far apart in you
know different different continents
separated by oceans that kind of thing
to have effective
personal communications
okay now
can i just say a lot of you flatly
missed that okay you said things like ah
teleconferencing you sort of um saw it
in a very bifurcated contrasty way so
you're like teleconferencing is the way
the future you can see people it's um
it's really personal whereas telephones
you can't have a relationship with
someone over a telephone that's
ridiculous you know stop living in the
past you know are you still writing on
stone tablets that kind of thing okay
what lies total lies telephones um and
face-to-face communication right
they're great ways to have
personal sort of communication okay an
interaction right if i had said okay
what about say text messaging that would
have been a different question that
would be a significantly different
question because um communicating by
just written text
is not an effective way to have personal
communications okay now i'll admit right
and we'll get onto this in a second
teleconferencing is superior it's better
okay um at least when you're trying to
talk about um the personal level of it
but
you know
i know about you guys maybe this is
showing my age okay but you know when i
had when
high school good friends um you know
friends of the friends of the opposite
gender if you wanted to have a
relationship you got on the phone right
like because you can't you're not meant
to talk in your in your you know maths
class for that kind of thing um so the
phone is really good okay you don't get
face-to-face contact that's fine we'll
address that in a second but
you get remote communications and it's
effective in communicating personal
things okay so you should say that about
these two they're not that different in
that regard
okay
but
that sort of implies some differences
right away okay they're not remote in
the same way okay they're not remote in
the same way
how does the telephone call work what
system does it rely on
it's got a name this system
it's a four letter acronym
pstm which stands for
go at that you've got the internet yeah
okay close enough so you've got this
you're generally speaking you've got
copper network you've got underlying uh
under underground sorry or under ocean
rather um
uh c undersea cables right and you've
got this established network which
provides for this
um communications okay but
teleconferencing is different
um the the question actually very
specifically says it doesn't happen
through a dedicated network at least
this kind of teleconference it happens
through the internet
okay now right away that tells you i'm
moving from a compare into a contrast
here right there's differences in
requirements of hardware okay and this
is starting to leach into the next
question but it's an important point of
contrast okay probably the big thing
that you need is therefore a high speed
connection
now this is um not to be overlooked
because you know what if you
pick up the phone and you call someone
in um you know in sydney
or interstate or overseas right
if it's through a landline phone this is
quite astonishing you get much the same
experience
if you if you call someone within
your city within your metropolitan or
somewhere else in the country or
somewhere else like on the opposite of
the world you get a very similar
experience they sound very similar there
might be a slight delay but not much
okay
now why is that because this system
has been developed to provide that exact
experience okay and there's not as much
broad uh bandwidth required just to
transmit audio okay
but it's not the same when you're going
over the internet okay so you need you
can't just have any connection right you
can't have some dingy sort of you know
i've got my 3g that kind of thing um you
need a really significantly high speed
internet connection in order to make
teleconferencing work
um in a you know effective way
okay so there's a there's a compare and
there's a contrast
right let's keep moving
all right now let's let's dive into that
audio and uh visual visual difference
right
that if you are
are lacking the visual when you're
having a telephone conversation okay
what's the actual concrete difference
that it makes think about the business
right
think about these guys
they're working together okay what's the
actual differences
in the organization professionally
speaking right in terms of business
if you can't see the person who you're
working with
someone tell me what kind of differences
are you gonna have
steve what do you reckon if you could
never see the people who you're working
with from different offices that kind of
thing what differences do you think that
would make to you as an employee of one
of these kinds of companies
okay all right let's let's let's go with
that all right trust
trust
why do you single out trust why is that
why do you think trust might be harder
yeah okay all right let's keep going at
that right so we prefer face to face
um if we're doing something important
but why is that like
why
why why not be able to just you organize
you can organize lots of things over the
phone right why do we have this
preference someone want to help them out
that's the person
ah good okay now i i'm gonna suggest
probably trust me is not the best thing
to go after because if we're in an
organization we're trying to be
professional i'm going to rely on this
person even if i can't see their face
okay but there's still something real
here that it's and this is what i would
say right even though there's
it's an effective mean of personal
communications it's harder to build a
relationship
even a professional one right if you
can't see someone's face that's really
difficult actually okay if you're going
to be able to say this person is my boss
or this person i i have to liaise with
them every day or every week or
something like that
you have professional relationships and
those are harder to build okay
so
um maybe rather than trust i'd say it's
about the relationship between the
people who are working
okay and i don't make this to sound too
airy fairy or emotional but
relationships are important in any kind
of
venture where like we said we're working
on like a big project we want to know
these people well um know how they work
and it's hard to just do that over the
phone okay
um part of part of why by the way why
it's so difficult is because body
language gets missed
you know i don't know if you've read the
stats or heard about them about how much
you know verb yeah something like that
so verbal communication right you've got
all these different levels of
communication there's the words you say
there's the words you say and you could
convey them just as you know a text
message okay and then there's things
like tone and pauses and uh so they're
more auditory things and then beyond
that you've got okay
how does someone's face look okay what's
their body like all those kinds of
things and they're a language they
communicate a lot of stuff right so as
you go to through levels of abstraction
um away from face to face and you know
down to probably the bottom is text
communication um you're missing these
things okay it's why emoticons for for
all of their you know silliness actually
serve a purpose okay
anyway
so there's a contrast
all right now let's